and it is chris bassett as detail what
an outstanding performance by
bass against the angels last weekend in
anaheim and seven and two-thirds innings
gave up just a couple of hits
justin upton batting 204 he swings it's
a high pot
short right field biscotti finding the
sun it's a tough play out there
and he makes the catch and that's the
way our ball game begins and there's one
gun for bassett that'll bring up shohei
ohtani not pitching but d.h
and for further explanation here's
angel's manager joe madden
it's not him it's in general uh the bus
coming over
i guess there was an accident on the bay
bridge which caused us to take plan b
and they had to go on back and
jump on the bart and then there was an
issue with the transfer on the bart
and that kept pushing him back and for
us shohei's most comfortable
getting because he's pretty much uh
regimented to get everything going about
four o'clock for a start so
that was it exceeded by maybe an hour so
we started calling the audible at that
point
strike three call good fastball on the
inside corner
so bassett freezes ohtani for the second
half
two pitch got him swinging with the slow
curve couple of strikeouts for bassett
well patrick sandoval threw 83 pitches
on saturday against the a's it was his
biggest workload of the year
out there to make his third starting
assignment of the season tonight
seventh pitch of the at-bat and he
strikes him out
he went 3-2 change-up on him a real good
arm action on this one too
sharply hit the first walsh goes up the
ladder to get it
and nothing comes to the lead-off walk
on to the second
in oakland patrick sandoval has
completed his warm-up tosses as we move
now to the bottom of the second
payoff pitch got him swinging but
his jump takes care of jed lowry his
change-up is such a good pitch it is
such a non-contact pitch
here's the one-two delivery and there's
a swing and a miss and he threw it by
him
struck him out swinging back-to-back
strikeouts for sandy and he's retired
three on strikeouts in this ball game
one gone for david fletcher
strike three call so bassett paints the
corner and that is his fourth strikeout
always a big win anytime you can lock up
the fletch god
because he's got some incredible bat to
ball skill
swings and misses two more strikeouts
for bass that he's got
five through the first three innings no
score and a payoff pitch to the a's
chad pinder and it's inside and low ball
four not even close we tried soft again
with the changeup that's going to load
the bases for ramon loriano
two and two the count here on lariano
bases loaded
the pitch and this is grounded to third
could be two
second for one relay to first got him
and that is how the inning will end boy
oh boy
just what sandoval needed and he got it
so still 0-0 game top of the fifth
inning just four hits total angels with
one
the a's with three and he lightens it
right into the glove of matt olson and
that's the first down
under the glove of rojas into center
field and lowry has the a's third hit
and jeff lowry right back up the middle
and somehow this made it all the way
through
and off the glove rojas
[Applause]
on the ground rolled right to rendon who
will cut down
lowry to retire the side another runner
left stranded
and a lot of congratulations for patrick
sandoval
after five shutout innings tonight and
an 11th hour start
the top of the sixth inning no score
[Applause]
still looking for it and he is able to
turn around
get back just a little bit and make a
basket catch wow
what a recovery so lost it
found it right at the end right-hander
aaron slagers comes out of the bullpen
to work for the angels our ball game
goes to the bottom of the six there's
matt olson now
olson shoots one down the third base
line and it's headed into the left field
corner
and matt olsen is going to have a thing
of beauty
that's a double just inside out we saw
him do it yesterday
slicing the ball down the third base and
left field foul line our left field line
and
there's just absolutely nobody they're
going to give it to him but
i'll be honest with the way this game is
going scoreless from the bottom the
sixth inning
running scores that's a couple of
opportunities for the a's to
score one and take a lead
so jed lowry steps up and that one's
outside and lowry takes the four pitch
walk
two on one out for chapman first pitch
to chapman
grounded in the hole fletcher's got it
fletcher's throw to 30. threw it away
bounces off the sidewall olson's going
to come in to score
everybody moves up and the a's take a
one-nothing lead
this was going to be the only play that
fletcher had trying to get this ball
over to third base you can see rindon
he's not anticipating this ball coming
to him
he initially breaks in not towards the
bag and he has to readjust and try to
make a play on the throw
and by that time he's already out of
position the throws off line
madelson's gonna head into home jed
lowry is going to come around into third
base but you can see right here
rindon has to turn his body back to his
glove side to try to get to that
baseball
and just no shot so here's murphy
a little pop-up shallow center lagarus
upton and it falls and both runs are
going to score
chapman reddick perfect and he was right
on the heels of lowry
it's three to nothing this is almost
like it's a don for time that uh
jeff lowry's gonna hand off to watch
after the spring
he was halfway to third right behind
jett lowry here comes
matt chapman i mean neither one slid the
chappie saw it knew where the outfitters
are playing
and that's your job when you get on base
yeah he had to slow down a little bit so
he's
putting past jed lower brown will face
claudio's a new pitcher and a pinch
hitter
that pitches outside walking elvis
andrews
grounded into right field the base hit
here comes murphy
here comes the throw to the plate he's
safe four-nothing a's
the right-hander junior guerra comes on
for the angels the third pitcher they've
used in the spot over the six
so brown is at third andrews is at
second can is that first one out and
here's tony kemp
kent to center magaris sets up
brown tags brown coming in and brown
will score
with a head first slide and it's five to
nothing give tony kemp the sacrifice fly
and the rbi after 60 years of cruising
now they lead five nothing we go to the
seventh and there's vince with an
efficient
chris bassett on the mound 76 pitches
through six innings
now right back to bassett he's got it
underhand toss to olson one two three
for
sea bass and he is cruising here's chris
bassett going for the
shutout pitch is hit to right center
it's hit deep but it's playable brown
tracks it down in right center field
bounce to short anders has it flips it
across
and that's the ball again so this night
belongs to chris bassett
a two-hit shutout his first
career shutout